يقال يعني الذين كتبوا عن شغلك انه يوجد
مقدار جميل وعالي من السرد ايضا في قصيده
محمد الاشعري ربما بطريقه غير غير واعيه
وغير مفكر فيها
من بدايات الشعريه
انصرفت الى تركيب حكايات نعم الى حكايه
نعم من خلال القصيده وربما ابرز عمل كان
في هذا الاطار هو ديوان سيره المطار
وسيره المطار هو عنوان القصيده الاساسيه
في هذا الديوان
وهي نوع من الاستعاده البطيئه والمفصله
لصبيحه واحده في قريه في بيت قروي وهذا
الاستعاده
هي من طفولتي
وانتبهت الى ان المجال الذي وضعته اطارا
للقصيده ومجال فقير جدا فقير في الاحداث
فقير في الاشياء فقير في مكونات المكان
ولكن في هذا الفقر المدع
هناك كميه من من الجمال المتوحش
والغير المعلن عن نفسه
لا يصدق
وحاولت ان احكي هذه الصبيحه التي شهدت في
نفس الوقت حدثا دراميا هو موت اخي صغير في
ذلك اليوم وخروجه صبيا وهذه حقيقه يعني
وخروجه صبيا بين يدي والدي الى المقبره
ولكن في نفس الوقت هناك ام تصنع خبزها
وشخص اخر يكنس الفناء الداخلي
لي وهناك خوخه يابسه قرب البئر اشياء من
هذا النوع هي التي اسست لهذه القصيده لهذه
القصيده هي التي كتبتها يوم ماطر فقير
ليست فيه اشياء
خارقه للعاده ولكنه يوم
لكنه يوم
تجربه في في الحكي الشعري اذا صح هذا
المصطلح
رافقتني بعد ذلك
لسنوات يبدو هي كانت الحجر الاساس اللي
ربما انا قلت لك لم افكر في الامر
بهذه الطريقه لكن صاحبني الى اليوم